all of Sheriff I genuinely do not seek  to stifle robust debate but this evening  the Prime Minister has continually used  pejoratively which to describe an Act of  Parliament passed by this house with  degree Mr Speaker we should not resort  to using offensive for legislation that  we do not like mr. speaker when most  moderate our language and it has to come  from the Prime Minister his opinion he  should be absolutely shamed  I think mrs. Speaker I have to take mr.  speaker right I have to say mr. speaker  I've never heard such humbug in all my  life  [Applause]  jeez  [Applause]  order order order order order order  order order  [Applause]